horrible story story over the weekend a
38 year old mother of four was driving
uber to make some extra money
and
a man gets in her she was 38 years old
i you can tell by the word was that this
story is not going to turn out very well
a 22 year old guy gets in calvin crew
and he puts a gun to the back of her
head and he says hey
uh
give me your money
she says no please i don't have this
money i don't have this please put the
gun down no no no she goes please i have
a family i have four kids he says no no
no no eventually the camera goes out he
shoots her
this guy calvin crew
even though he's only 22 years old he's
a career criminal he's got a rap sheet a
mile long
he's been in and out of the system since
he was a young teenager
he's got an active criminal case right
now involving a firearm
why was this animal allowed to prowl the
streets
why
because of criminal justice reform of
course
we hear criminal justice reform mostly
from the libs but sometimes some
conservatives embrace it too frankly i
mean trump pushed this kind of stuff to
some degree
and we hear oh this is good this is
going to let
you know people who are getting life
sentences for for smoking one puff of a
joint one time this is that's it's gonna
these more frivolous prosecutions
that's not how it works criminal justice
reform in practice is letting these
monsters these animals out on the street
to run roughshod to terrorize innocent
people to destroy law and we can't do it
we think that justice in america today
is letting all the criminals out of the
prisons abolishing prisons as some very
prominent democrats elected democrats
have been talking about is it any wonder
is it any wonder that our enemies are
taking advantage
we got we've got more hits the hits just
keep on coming out of our the criminal
justice reform
movement
four people were stabbed on a new york
city subway platform or on a new york
city subway train
on saturday within 18 hours within 18
hours
among you know new york's not a very big
city
four people stabbed within 18 hours
this as mayor eric adams is going to get
tougher on crime yeah okay
what happened three suspects stabbed a
46 year old homeless man seven times
after attempting to rob him
on the three train at livonia and
vanciclon avenue in brooklyn a man
punched a 20 year old woman in the back
and then uh when she objected to getting
punched in the back uh he slashed her
three times in the stomach two teens uh
slashed a 24 year old man standing in
the mezzanine because he i guess the
robbery didn't go right he didn't just
immediately give them everything they
wanted
and a 31 year old man
was standing near a man and a woman on a
train while the woman was smoking
and apparently this started in an
argument and the man from the couple
stabbed the guy
criminal justice reform right
that isn't that great we need to let
these people out of prison we the our
problem you know what our problem is in
america over incarceration that's what i
say
how can you believe you have to be
so miseducated you have to be so
completely deluded you've got to be so
high not on the haitian oregano but on
on ideology
that you believe
that a man is
really a woman
that you believe
that there's white supremacy go just
wait for the white supremacy we got a
great white supremacy story coming up
white supremacy running rough shot over
america
and you believe that our biggest problem
in the criminal justice system
is over incarceration we have a severe
under incarceration problem we don't
deal
with crime and justice anymore
we have a lot of problems and it's not
even just the basic political problems
all the border doesn't work oh we've got
this economic issue oh we've no it's
it's a philosophical problem we don't
know what justice is we think that
justice is letting criminals out of
prison
is it any wonder
that our enemies are aggressing i'm glad
you like that clip now
this is important
ring that bell
subscribe you'll get notifications you
can also head on over to apple podcast
spotify stitcher google play wherever
you get your audio podcast subscribe to
the michael knowles show leave a five
star review we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]